[Música]
estamos con el señor alexandr
goncharenko alcalde de la ciudad de
crematorios y la ciudad más importante
del donbass actualmente en poder del
gobierno de ucrania que se ha convertido
en esa capital militar y gubernamental
de esta zona del donbass alcalde gracias
por estar con france24 y cuál es la
situación en la región especialmente en
la ciudad después de esa llamada pausa
operativa del gobierno ruso
lo que es una realidad declamatoria es
que vemos que los ocupantes rusos
empezaron a atacar más seguido las
ciudades como karma torch
en la última semana ya han atacado hama
torsos tres veces la última por la
mañana a las cuatro
y bombardearon una planta industrial
por ahora no hay víctimas ni heridos
porque la planta estaba cerrada
había parado su producción el primero de
marzo de este año
el
14 está cerca de slobodan se iba como
que son esas dos grandes ciudades hacia
dónde se dirigen las próximas batallas
del ejército de moscú cómo se prepara la
ciudad para ese ataque
por ahora la situación general en cuanto
a bombardeos y ataques es más o menos
tranquila
si se compara con lo que está ocurriendo
en ciudades como saludaron
porque están un poco lejos de nosotros
su línea del combate está en dirección
sureste de 14
por tanto los combates en esa dirección
se producen ahora a una distancia de 60
a 65 kilómetros
los combates más cercanos a granados
northwest
estar en la dirección norte noreste
noroeste colina o sea que los combates
en esa dirección se producen ahora a una
distancia de 40 a 45 kilómetros es decir
20 kilómetros más cerca que si se
compara con bajamos y por lo tanto se
escuchan enormes explosiones y enormes
bombardeos desde la dirección norte
es lo bien que está muy cerca de aquí
son más o menos 15 kilómetros y
definitivamente un ataque a esta ciudad
afectará directamente a grama torch
cuales esas estrategias que ustedes
están haciendo para evitar que las
fuerzas rusas lleguen hasta allí y para
ayudar también a la población
se dice les piten crematorios que nos
odian
la distancia entre crematorio y slogans
que esté sólo 12 kilómetros
entonces si nosotros os comienzan a
atacar cada día con más fuerza es lo
bianco podría decirse que también
atacará en la zona de cama tours podría
ser posible
sí pero como se están preparando cuáles
son esas alternativas que ustedes están
tomando para proteger y ayudar a la
gente de crematorio
y llevamos aproximadamente cinco meses
preparándonos desde el inicio de la
guerra total contra ucrania
por lo tanto hemos hecho muchas cosas en
este tiempo y tenemos suficiente
almacenamiento de medicinas dice
gasolina gas y algunos alimentos para el
peor de los casos si se rompen las vías
logísticas de la grama torso así que
hemos hecho muchos preparativos y hay
mucha gente que no se quiere ir por
muchísimos motivos con situación
económica porque son sus casas de toda
la vida porque después de cinco meses de
guerra ya no quiere ser más refugiados
como están ustedes ayudando qué
alternativas les dan a esa gente para
que salgan de aquí ustedes han venido
presionando en los últimos días para que
la población evacúe la próxima en el
instituto del propio visión como por
ahora tenemos aproximadamente el 30 por
ciento de la población total
si se compara con la población antes del
comienzo de la guerra total contra
ucrania eso significa que el 70% se ha
ido aproximadamente 150.000
frontex y aproximadamente 65 mil están
todavía en la ciudad
y por la experiencia de otras ciudades
por ejemplo lysychansk
entendemos que para nuestro ejército en
ese caso es más difícil proteger las
ciudades si mucha gente se queda porque
es más difícil
existe el peligro de que nuestra gente
muera por los disparos de los rusos si
nuestro ejército empieza a disparar
contra rusia ellos inmediatamente
dispararán de vuelta y eso dañaría a las
casas de la gente en primer lugar de
gente moriría
así que cuanta menos gente haya en una
ciudad o en un pueblo más fácil es para
los militares proteger la ciudad
y es más fácil luchar contra los rusos
por lo tanto hemos dejado de pedir a la
gente
y mucha gente en europa o en otros
países e incluso aquí en ucrania se
preguntara por qué a seguir peleando por
el donbass donde han muerto cientos y
cientos de jóvenes una zona donde en
algunos sectores incluso hay gente que
prefiere estar del lado ruso que del
lado craneano porque pelear por el
donbass
porque es nuestra tierra y tenemos que
luchar por ella
y donbass crematorio rubiáns son
ciudades ucranianas es bastante difícil
mantener económicamente a una ciudad
como como clama torch como están
haciendo ustedes para mantenerla a flote
en estas circunstancias como infernal
knauf resources manifestarse asfalto ok
tenemos suficientes recursos monetarios
que deberían ser suficientes hasta
octubre noviembre según nuestros
cálculos pero ya veremos qué pasa
después tal vez necesitemos alguna ayuda
del gobierno hasta finales de año pero
esta octubre o noviembre los recursos
monetarios deberían ser suficientes
esta ha sido una ciudad que ha estado
rodeada por la guerra desde 2014
básicamente para muchos sectores del
donbass están en poder de las fuerzas
rusas como afectado y como se ha
mantenido la ciudad hasta ahora y como
ha cambiado después de la guerra
comenzada en febrero el costo o
industria metalúrgica plan de business
es perdimos todas las plantas
industriales y metalúrgicas los negocios
tal vez perdimos un 50% en las zonas
ocupadas
así que perdimos el 50 por ciento de
nuestra economía hace 8 años
y
ahora perderemos las próximas plantas
industriales en negocios en las zonas
ocupadas por eso tenemos que defender a
los rusos inmediatamente
de lo contrario perderemos todo en la
región de dobletes y los rusos no ocupan
son los ciudades y pueblos ocupan
territorios
y
si se acercan a un pueblo oa una ciudad
están empezando a cerrar totalmente las
otras ciudades son destruidas un 90 por
ciento comunicantes
y lo único que hacen es ocupar el
territorio del territorio la tierra y
para terminar hay una gran población o
una población significativa
que apoya y que simpatiza con el
gobierno de moscú mientras que hay otra
gran población que simpatiza con el
gobierno ucraniano
eventualmente llega un momento de paz
cómo hacer para que ambas poblaciones
convivan en la misma ciudad bajo estas
circunstancias
es people who
using tuvo todas observar sus people son
personas que creen que aman a los rusos
nadie los va a sacar de nuestra ciudad
sin embargo las cosas que se sienten
cómodos viviendo en nuestra ciudad
porque han vivido en crematorios durante
los últimos ocho años
creo que no hay mucha gente que sea
prorrogado por pipo
creo que no hay muchos porque hace ocho
años teníamos aproximadamente un 40% de
la población que apoyaba las ideas rusas
o las ideas de las regiones separatistas
roxana díaz orden general díaz en after
y después de que se liberara la ciudad
después de que salieran de nuestra
región
la mayoría de los que apoyaban las ideas
rusas en el pasado cambiaron su
mentalidad
creo que no hay más de un 5% que apoyará
en el futuro las ideas de rusia y las
regiones separatistas